à coignières ville de 4394 habitants
deux candidats s'opposent
xavier girard tête de liste de
coignières à venir l'homme politique de
51 ans est cadre dans le service
automobile l'habite la ville depuis onze
ans ce quoi n'ya rien s'est lancé depuis
2018 en politique après la fusion ratée
entre coignières et maurepas coignières
est une ville à gros potentiel avec de
nombreux enjeux des défis
environnementaux sociétal technologique
nous pensons que le cogneur à venir à
des idées qui peuvent être défendus
devant un conseil municipal deuxième
liste un élan durable pour coignières
mené par le maire sortant didier fischer
en place depuis 14 mois l'homme
politique de 62 ans de sensibilité de
gauche est arrivé à coignières en 2007
est devenu conseiller municipal en 2008
il a également été conseiller régional
de 2004 à 2015 on a effectivement
entrepris un travail important déjà il
ya un vrai bilan qui commence à être
connue là par les coignet rien mais ce
bilan n'est rien par rapport à ce qu'il
reste à faire il faut effectivement
continuer le travail et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle évidemment je me
représente aujourd'hui